[Musica]
il panda è un animale in via di
estinzione perché il suo habitat si sta
rimpicciolendo a causa della
deforestazione
quindi per lui è sempre più difficile
trovare da mangiare trovare dei germogli
di bambù e per questo motivo il panda
non ha tanta scelta o l'ecosistema
intorno a lui cambia oppure si
estinguerà questa sono io in una foto
vintage di qualche anno fa
anzi più di venti per la verità era il
giorno della mia laurea in economia era
una ragazza di napoli quindi avevo
tantissimi sogni volevo tra le tante
cose crescere fare carriera diventare
una manager e diventare direttore
marketing in un'azienda e così come
funzionava la fine degli anni 90 ho
lasciato la mia città sono andate a
studiare fuori in un'altra città ho
studiato marketing comunicazione
ho iniziato con uno stage a milano non
retribuito e poi ho cambiato vari lavori
e mano mano sono cresciuta ho fatto
carriera e sono diventata poi tanti anni
dopo una manager non soltanto o anche
raggiunto il mio obiettivo perché sono
diventata la responsabile di una
divisione marketing in una grande
multinazionale ma mi ero talmente
concentrata su questa mia carriera e su
questo passaggio di studio stage lavoro
retribuzione riconoscimento che non mi
ero accorta che il mondo intorno a me
era cambiato stava cambiando che le
aziende cambiavano e che anche i lavori
cambiavano e quindi non mi sono resa
conto che forse io ero rimasta nella mia
direttrice così un giorno mi chiamano in
azienda mi dicono gabriella devi
cambiare lavoro devi lasciare il
marketing
ovviamente le interpretazioni sono state
varie in questa questa richiesta che mi
hanno fatto anche le mie considerazioni
e io ovviamente ero resistente a questo
cambiamento ma alla fine devo così cosa
decido di fare mi propongono un altro
lavoro
simile a quello che già facevo in
un'altra direzione che probabilmente ne
avrebbe dato la possibilità di fare
ancora carriera e forse di raggiungere
dei ruoli è ancora apicali ma io decido
invece di prendere un'altra strada
perché penso che se il mondo stava
cambiando le aziende cambiavano anche i
lavori stavano cambiando forse io dovevo
guardare il mio futuro in una maniera
diversa e quindi decido invece di
accettare di aprire un piccolo
laboratorio dell'innovazione all'interno
della mia azienda che era praticamente
inesistente senza risorse con pochissime
diciamo disponibilità e soprattutto
senza una chiara visione del futuro
tant'è che vado dal mio nuovo capo il
giorno in cui iniziò questa questo nuovo
lavoro e gli chiedo che cosa devo fare
lui mi guarda dopo un pò di silenzio e
mi dice non ne ho idea
e così è iniziato il mio nuovo lavoro
per cui ho iniziato davvero con una
start up era in azienda per cui da
manager mi sono trasformata in una intra
premier
voi vi chiederete che cosa mi accomuna
con il panda in realtà niente perché il
panda
non ha scelta e quindi rischia di
estinguersi perché l'ecosistema intorno
non cambia
io invece ho deciso di adeguarmi
all'ecosistema intorno e quando ho
iniziato diciamo questo mio percorso
nell'innovazione
mi sono resa conto che avevo davvero una
passione per l'innovazione e questo è
stato un driver di scelta molto forte
per me ma non avevo assolutamente idea
di che cosa fosse l'innovazione ero
totalmente ignorante mi piaceva mi
piacevano le tecnologie
ero appassionata ero curiosa di leggere
informazioni sulle tecnologie ma non lo
sapevo non sapevo che cosa fosse e
quindi mi sono resa conto di essere
diventata un intraprendere dopo quando
ero già nel nuovo ruolo ma l'inter apre
nel chip è qualcosa che adesso è
diventata di gran moda ma in realtà è un
concetto molto vecchio perché ha più di
40 anni è un concetto che è stato
inventato da due ragazzi che studiavano
a new york nella scuola di
imprenditorialità e che in realtà dice
che l'inter a prender ship non è altro
che l'applicazione dei principi che
normalmente un imprenditore utilizza
all'interno di un'organizzazione
strutturata e con anche diciamo facendo
leva sulle metodologie tipiche delle
start up per creare innovazione
quindi non è altro che un imprenditore
all'interno di un'azienda semplicemente
perché adesso è tornata così di moda
questo concetto perché le aziende si
sono rese conto che non soltanto i
manager forze devono diventare intra 3
nerma che le aziende stesse devono
iniziare ad agire come una start up
perché perché comunque c'è una necessità
impellente di innovare innovare non
soltanto con le tecnologie con
l'innovazione come la intendiamo noi
quindi non soltanto aprendoci verso il
mercato con l'open innovation ma anche
facendo leva sulle risorse dell'azienda
stessa con nuovi modi di organizzare il
lavoro con nuovi processi aziendali come
loro krazia o altre cose di questo tipo
perché soltanto così si riesce a far
emergere da dai dipendenti dell'azienda
il loro vero potenziale e si fa in modo
che l'azienda riesca a rimanere sul
mercato o addirittura l'iter di mercato
perché questo perché per essere in linea
con il progresso che in passato era
lineare è stato per secoli lineare ma
che adesso è diventato esponenziale le
aziende devono innovare con una velocità
maggiore perché esponenziale è un
concetto che abbiamo preso dalla
matematica e che significa semplicemente
che la lunghezza dell'ultimo passo è
pari all'intero percorso precedentemente
intrapreso per capire meglio questo
concetto mi rifaccio ad un film che è
molto famoso quasi tutti penso in questa
sala loro hanno visto in tutto in parte
che è il ritorno al futuro
in questo film il ragazzo interprete che
marty mcfly interpretato da michael j
fox è un ragazzo che dal 1985 è l'anno
in cui e stato fatto il film ritorna al
1955 quindi 30 anni prima quando i suoi
genitori si sono conosciuti che cosa
vede questo ragazzo un mondo diverso
vede delle televisioni antiquate vede un
linguaggio anche diverso da quello che
lui utilizzava così come i prezzi delle
cose erano bassissimi
immaginatevi se marty mcfly invece di
tornare indietro di trent'anni dal 1985
fosse tornato indietro di trent'anni dal
2015 al 1985
quello che lui avrebbe visto è qualcosa
di enormemente diverso quei trent'anni
non sono gli stessi trent'anni che
c'erano prima
ecco questa è la teoria che un
futurologo che si chiama kurt weill
spiega nella teoria del ritorno
accelerato
secondo lui tutto il progresso del
ventesimo secolo lo abbiamo avuto
nuovamente tra il 2000 e 2014
e se avrà nuovamente tra il 2014 e il
con un tempo sempre più ridotto quindi
tra vent'anni non avremmo l'equivalente
del progresso del ventesimo secolo
addirittura più volte nello stesso anno
e successivamente più volte nello stesso
mese
questo vuol dire che nel 2050 quindi tra
30 anni il mondo sarà talmente diverso
da oggi che non lo possiamo nemmeno
immaginare intelligenza artificiale nel
2023 si stima che sarà equivalente
all'intelligenza di un essere umano ma
nel 2045
e sempre una stima si stima che
l'intelligenza artificiale sarà
equivalente al totale delle intelligenze
di tutti gli esseri umani presenti sulla
terra
che cosa vuol dire questo per le aziende
come impatta questo sulla vita delle
aziende
sicuramente qualcuno di voi o tutti
avranno in passato ha avuto un cellulare
non uno smart phone un cellulare avranno
noleggiato una videocassetta un dvd
avranno acquistato un rullino per la
macchina fotografica analogica benissimo
che fine hanno fatto le queste aziende
che erano leader di mercato
quindici anni fa sono sparite perché non
si sono rese conto che il mondo stava
cambiando e hanno continuato a fare
quello che facevano molto bene prima ad
esempio c'è una nota azienda produttrice
di rullini fotografici che per prima ha
inventato la macchina fotografica
digitale nel 1975 ma non l'ha mai messo
sul mercato perché ha preferito
sviluppare rullini sempre più
performanti che cosa vuol dire questo
a volte le aziende hanno la sindrome del
del risultato di breve periodo un po c'è
anche l'eredità tecnologica ma c'è anche
la paura di cannibalizzare il business
che funziona quindi il non volersi
assumere dei rischi che cosa succede
quindi alle aziende che se all'inizio
del secolo le aziende avevano una durata
media di 67 anni
oggi questa durata media è diventata di
15 anni si stima che tra dieci anni il
40 per cento delle
1500 aziende al mondo l'istat e dall
indice americano standard poor non
esisteranno più
e se andiamo a guardare nella storia
quelle che erano presenti nella lista
delle prime 500 aziende stilate dalla
rivista americana forbes
di queste ne sono rimaste soltanto il 12
per cento nel 2017
quindi che cosa succederà in futuro
questo che vedete nella nell'immagine un
taxi degli anni 60 con le ali perché
quando ero bambina guardavo questo
cartone animato si chiamava i pronipoti
nel quale c'era questa famiglia degli
anni 60 che viveva nello spazio e
andavano al lavoro con la macchina
volante e io quando ero bambina pensavo
che questo non sarebbe mai potuto
succedere mai invece quest'anno hanno
presentato il taxi volante che sarà nei
cieli dal 2025 una nota azienda
produttrice di aerei quindi quello che
sembrava impossibile in passato è
diventato attuale
quali sono gli effetti di tutto questo
sulla vita delle persone immaginiamoci
soltanto i lavori
no c'è un noto sito di internet di
ricerca lavoro che ha stilato una lista
di quelli che sono i lavori che nei
prossimi anni spariranno tra questi ce
ne sono alcuni abbastanza diciamo ob
il lettore di contatori il controllore
delle tasse ma ad esempio pare che anche
il postino sparirà in favore dei dei
droni piuttosto che le hostess di volo
addirittura e gioiellieri se ce n'è
qualcuno tra di voi
pare che vengano sostituiti
dall'intelligenza artificiale queste
cose ci sembrano molto strane ma voi
immaginate che noi
dieci anni fa ho 15 anni fa non avremmo
mai immaginato che le professioni più
ricercate oggi che sono ad esempio il
manager dei social media o anche il data
scientist perché non le conoscevamo non
esistevano non c'era quel lavoro non
c'erano i social media quindi ovviamente
non c'era nemmeno il manager dei social
media
e così per il futuro ad esempio il
governo americano ha fatto commissionato
una ricerca per capire quali potessero
essere le professioni del futuro
e pare che tra le più gettonate ci siano
un esempio costruttore di parti
anatomiche del corpo umano artificiale
ovviamente così come i coltivatori delle
fattorie verticali quelle che
risparmiano energia e acqua
piuttosto che gli architetti che faranno
case ecologiche su marte ci sembrano
lavori assurdi però ci sembravano anche
assurdi lavori come quelli che oggi
invece sono i più ricercati i più pagati
perché perché il tempo di dimezzamento
delle competenze professionali di una
persona nel 1984 era di 30 anni oggi è
di 5 anni e le materie che gli studenti
studiano oggi tecnologiche o
scientifiche a scuola e all'università
al primo anno al terzo anno sono già
parzialmente obsolete quindi che cosa
succede che cosa bisogna fare il premio
nobel yunus che è anche un professore di
economia dice che secondo lui tutti noi
siamo nati come imprenditori perché
perché eravamo nelle caverne cipro
cacciavamo da mangiare
davamo da mangiare agli animali e
trovavamo nuove forme di lavoro ma poi
abbiamo perso tutto questo perché la
civilizzazione il progresso ci hanno
portato a verticalizzare cia
specializzarci a ripetere sempre le
stesse attività e siamo diventati
manodopera
lui dice ecco bisogna ritrovare questo
istinto primordiale di imprenditori che
dentro di noi e non è l'unico che
diciamo afferma questo perché anche uno
dei co founder di linkedin insieme ad un
altro scrittore americano hanno scritto
appunto un testo che si chiama the start
up o view molto interessante nel quale
loro partono proprio da questo principio
e dicono visto che la specializzazione
non sarà più premiata in futuro e
ripetere per 30 anni 40 anni come i
nostri genitori lo stesso lavoro non è
più una cosa sostenibile quello che
bisogna fare
e sempre in uno stato di work in
progress in uno stato di perenne fase
beta in uno stato di learning quindi
crearsi una cultura continua e
soprattutto cercare di fare un lavoro
che coniuga la passione con l'esigenza
del mercato se hai solo la passione non
mangi devi anche fare qualcosa che ti
remuneri e ti consenta di di vivere
bisogna avere un piano a un piano b ma
anche un piano z
bisogna correre dei rischi misurati
bisogna avere coraggio
ecco questa sono io qualche anno dopo un
po più vecchia più di vent'anni dopo è
una foto di quattro mesi fa perché vi
ricordate quando vi dicevo che avevo la
passione dell'innovazione benissimo lo
coltivata l'ho fatta diventare un mio
lavoro non lavoro più nel ruolo che ho
scelto tre anni fa ma siccome avevo
desiderato un giorno accelerare start up
quindi lavorare in un centro di
innovazione ci sono riuscita ecco qui
siamo l'inaugurazione del centro di
innovazione che ora gestisco in cui mi
chiamano sindaco non avevo nessun tipo
di conoscenza non avevo nessuna cultura
dell'innovazione quando ho iniziato in
questo lavoro
avevo un foglio bianco e anche il mio
capo mi ha detto io non ho idea di che
cosa tu debba fare quindi che cosa ho
fatto oltre a studiare
ovviamente ho attinto a tutte le
conoscenze che avevo iniziato a scrivere
su questo foglio bianco e tante altre
persone hanno scritto con me ho creato
una cultura dell'innovazione e adesso il
mio obiettivo è quello di condividerla
all'interno di questo villaggio quindi
quello che posso dirvi e chiudo la mia
presentazione
se voi siete pronti per il futuro grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]